[Music]
who knew that tom selleck's character
frank reagan and cbs's blue bloods is
inspired by his friend and real-life
former new york city police commissioner
bill bratton did you know that donny
wahlberg is a big fan of nabbing on set
to join the long dinner scene shoots
here is the untold truth of blue bloods
it doesn't get a lot of media attention
or social media chatter but the numbers
don't lie blue bloods has long been one
of the most popular shows on tv ratings
for the series started strong and have
stayed that way over the last decade
plus it has become one of the more
quietly durable shows on the airwaves
like a lot of cbs hits blue bloods isn't
necessarily drawing in a ton of younger
viewers that is partly due to its slot
on friday nights when the coveted 18-49
demographic aren't at home watching tv
that being said the show has long ruled
the roost on fridays in terms of overall
viewership during its 12th season the
show pulled in roughly 6 million
households a week probably the best
known and most popular constant of blue
bloods is the family dinner scene almost
every episode has one and it helps to
maintain the sense of family that's a
through line for the series but these
scenes take as long as five hours to
film getting close-ups and coverage of
up to nine different characters takes
time as does resetting the table after
each take in order to maintain
continuity according to access hollywood
the actors tend to get a little stir
crazy during the long shoots and they
react in different ways bridget moynihan
gets the giggles while donnie wahlberg
has to take a nap because he eats the
prop dinner food all day long he told
access hollywood it's dinner right i
gotta eat tom selleck on the other hand
tries to eat all the meat but uses a
spit bucket for the rest of the meal
zelek also employs one other trick when
he's delivering a line or the camera is
on him he'll often start buttering his
bread this way he doesn't eat too much
and the continuity of his food props is
maintained
blue bloods was created by married
writing team mitchell burgess and robin
green after pending episodes for
northern exposure and party f5 they
reconnected with david chase he had
hired them in 1999 to write for a little
mob drama he'd created for hbo called
the sopranos burgess and green helped
craft the show in its early seasons and
were instrumental in its developments
then they left under murky circumstances
in 2006. according to brett martin's
book difficult men chase had reportedly
grown frustrated that the duo weren't
writing enough episodes and that what
they did write showed lack of
understanding for the nuances of the
established characters green reportedly
claimed that chase moved her chair at
the writers table to a far corner where
he wouldn't have to look at her the
account also reports that chase became
hostile and gave her and her husband a
list of grievances going back 20 years
then they were essentially fired
blue bloods has a show very much about
new york and new york people it's hard
to imagine this show filmed anywhere
else but just shortly after it started
shooting in 2010 the production almost
backed up and moved to toronto new york
city and state tax rebates for
production companies had expired making
the show hard to film in the very
expensive big apple the show's
production company negotiated a deal
with the states and city governments at
the last minute keeping blue bloods in
new york and out of canada
jennifer esposito was an original cast
member on blue bloods portraying
detective jackie cuolitola but according
to us weekly she collapsed on the set
during filming of the third season she'd
reportedly had a flare-up of celiac
disease a condition she'd had for years
it's a severe allergy to gluten found in
bread and grains which leads to a number
of ailments such as passing out
esposito's doctor recommended she go on
medical leave and she immediately took a
week off
according to esposito cbs didn't think
she was really that sick and was just
staying away from workers deployed to
get a race she asked for a reduced work
schedule which the network responded to
by firing her and issuing a statement to
the hollywood reporter that read
jennifer has informed us that she is
only available to work on a very limited
part-time schedule as a result she is
unable to perform the demands of her
role the press release also said that
the sudden disappearance of detective
kiritola would be explained by saying
she took a leave of absence to fill the
void actress megan boone was cast to
play a new detective
catholic advocacy organization the
catholic league once praised blue bloods
as quote one of the few tv shows to
treat catholicism fairly that's mainly
because straight-laced frank reagan has
been depicted as a devoted churchgoer
that all changed in 2014 when catholic
league president bill donohue claimed
his organization had been quote
bombarded with complaints when frank
commented on the church's attitude
towards homosexuality by saying well
i do believe that the church is a little
behind the times on this
the episode also featured a cardinal
struggling with his sexual identity as
well as a lesbian nun donohue suggested
that cbs was quote committing suicide
with what he felt was an attack on
catholics
a jersey city emergency medical
technician named adrian matilla appeared
as an extra and background actor
multiple times throughout the first
seasons of blue bloods he liked the
process of making tv so much that he
began pursuing more acting gigs oddly
enough the real-life public servant got
one of his first speaking roles on blue
bloods which ironically is a show about
public servants but his part in 2014
wasn't that of an emt or police officer
instead matilla was cast as a drug
dealer
on blue bloods tom selleck plays frank
reagan who is a fictitious new york city
police commissioner to prepare for the
part he didn't have to go far as he's
known new york city's real ex-police
commissioner bill bratton for years
stalek told tv guide that bratton quotes
had a lot of influence on him select
also read bratton's book turn around
which covers his years as police
commissioner under new york mayor rudy
giuliani select continued in the
interview with tv guide though they were
on the same page philosophically there
was a lot of conflict between the mayor
and his police commissioner this dynamic
mirrors scenarios that frequently play
out on blue bloods
not only were mitchell burgess and robin
green fired from the sopranos they were
fired from blue bloods as well according
to deadline cbs parted ways with the
creators at the end of season one
despite the show being a smash hit right
out of the gate cbs wanted the show to
be more of a formulaic police procedural
show like criminal minds or csi the
show's creative staff and actors wanted
it to be more of a blend of family drama
and exploration of the broad issues
facing police in modern society
ironically one of the show's first
bosses showrunner ken sanzil left the
show a few months earlier according to
deadline he reportedly became tired of
fighting with tom selleck who often
complained that the show's scripts were
too formulaic and procedural
amy carlson was part of the original
cast of blue bloods portraying linda
reagan an emergency room nurse who was
married to danny reagan
according to deadline coulson decided to
leave the show after season seven when
her contract with the series ran out the
show explained her absence with a
shocking revelation in the season 8
premiere when dany's therapist said then
she died in a helicopter crash
airlifting her patient
viewers were shocked and carlson didn't
much care for it either coulson said in
her interview with deadline i feel badly
that she dies the way she dies i did not
know they would do that i was surprised
i wouldn't have done that
since the beginning of blue blood's long
run will esters has played jaime reagan
who was the youngest son in the reagan
brood and an officer turned sergeant in
the new york police department estes
arguably knows the character of jaime
reagan better than anyone and he bought
when blue bloods writers decided to make
a romantic couple out of jaime and his
professional partner eddie janko played
by vanessa ray i never wanted them to
get together i hated the idea
blue bloods often explore the ethical
issues facing police officers a
particular focus is how selex frank
reagan balances doing the right thing
politically morally and personally it's
a complex puzzle that often doesn't have
an easy answer and one which played out
in the 2018 episode titled legacy rookie
officer rachel whitton played by lauren
patton detains a jaywalker as for his id
and then his immigration status the
situation escalates as observers record
it on their phone cameras the incident
makes headlines because it appears that
whitton racially profiled the jaywalker
even though she followed police
procedure to the letter frank reagan has
to fire officer witton for making the
nypd look bad but that ending didn't sit
well with selik according to tv guide
selik persuaded legacy writer ali
solomon to pen a new episode a year
later the episode titled milestones in
season 9 gave officer whitton a happier
ending in the episode frank goes to a
diner and finds that his server is
witten at a new year's resolution he
promises to admit he was wrong he
rehires witton and partners her with his
daughter-in-law eddie janko whitton's
reinstatement also brought patan back to
the show and she's appeared on more than
a dozen episodes in the now recurring
role
it's very difficult to get a license to
carry a handgun in new york city but
according to two sources who spoke to
the new york daily news tom selleck
bridget moyahan and will estes all
managed to get one the production
maintains a close relationship with the
new york city police department and
government which faced a corruption
scandal in 2019 when lieutenant paul
dean was sent to prison for bribery dean
alleged that his supervisor deputy
inspector mike endol pulled strings for
certain cast members of blue bloods to
get gun permits individuals who wouldn't
have been eligible if the rules had been
followed for example select didn't meet
the residency requirements while others
didn't provide proper documentation all
of this was reportedly approved by
ex-police commissioner bill bratton
whose wife ricky clemen appeared as a
judge on a 2014 blue bloods episode
additionally a production supervisor
paul cabbard had his license renewed
despite a 2012 domestic violence arrest
that should have led to a revoked
license on behalf of its actors a cbs
spokesperson said the blue bloods cast
members believed they were following the
appropriate application process
none of them are accused of any
wrongdoing
the cast and crew of blue bloods were
nearly finished producing season 10 when
production was shut down in the spring
of 2020 due to coronavirus only 19
installments were made so writers had to
shift a major platark resolution from
season 10 up to season 11 the
re-emergence of long-lost relative joe
hill showrunner kevin wade told deadline
we regrouped brought him back in the
beginning of season 11. it was funny to
start a season with this new character
and then to sort of let it go away wade
continued by saying that the show
couldn't film on location in the streaks
of new york as much as they'd done in
the past due to the pandemic blue bloods
became less of an action show and more
of a character drama at least for a
while according to the hollywood
reporter the production also considered
combating the disease by purchasing a
125 thousand dollar robot that uses
cutting edge light based technology to
kill the covert 19 virus
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you